et nous sommes en direct avec qu'on dise
lafarge organisatrice de la
manifestation parisienne et porte parole
du collectif antérieures jans bonjour et
merci d'être avec nous sur rt francs
sera longue à rallonge budgétaire prime
reprise de dette le gouvernement a fait
un parent etc son camp pour l'hôpital il
a été dévoilé il ya trois mois
manifestement pas suffisant puisque vous
êtes à nouveau dans la rue
la ministre de la santé estime ce qu'il
faut laisser le temps à ce plan d'
entrer pleinement en vigueur
que lui répondez vous aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
alors je le fais nous lui répondons à
travers le collectif d'urgence que ça
fait deux mois qu'on est en lutte avec
trois revendications qu'ils sont
simple que l'hôpital aujourd'hui dans
une crise sanitaire que le gouvernement
a laissé volontairement pour et
s'installer avec notre temps et
aujourd'hui il est vraiment temps de
réagir montant fait ma santé dans le dos
et en 2022
mais les soucis de l'hôpital c'est
maintenant la dégradation et les usagers
qui patientent trop de temps sur des
brancards à cause d'un dysfonctionnement
c'est pour aujourd'hui c'est pas en 2032
à défaut de moyens supplémentaires la
ministre de la santé laisse la porte
ouverte à la modification du mode de
gouvernance des établissements publics
elle s'est ainsi réduite presse à la
vous travaillez pour donner beaucoup
plus la main aux professionnels médicaux
ce sont les termes cela que c'est être
une solution à vos dieux pour mettre un
terme à la crise que traversent les
urgences
[Musique]
alors ça pourrait être un être humain
mais il va falloir se bouger un petit
peu plus rapidement que
avec ce besoin qui prévoit une nouvelle
rencontre un lit marx avec à des
médecins hospitaliers qu'est ce que vous
en attendez
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce qu'on en attendait on
sait que après onze mois une
mobilisation à l'ehess busan
n'a pas les clés et les mains pour
répondre à leurs revendications ça va
faire quelques mois qu'on en arbitrage à
monsieur emmanuel macron et à monsieur
edouard philippe
il est temps que le gouvernement se
saisisse de cette affaire dans la mesure
où ni madame busin lee monsieur darmanin
non les clés en boîte pour régler le
problème de l'hôpital qui en quelques
mots s'il fallait les résumés quels sont
aujourd'hui vos revendications
alors les revendications du collectif
intérieur jour seront pas changés depuis
11 mois
on demande à l'heure actuelle d'avoir
des locaux correct on demande également
à ce que nos patients aient des lits
d'hospitalisation post urgence et qu'ils
ne soient plus hospitaliser 15h 17h sur
des brancards
par manque de place mais qui dit manque
de place et du manque de personnel et en
fait on souffre d'un problème
d'attractivité donc on demande également
une revalorisation salariale à la
hauteur de 300 euros qui a eu ni plus ni
moins le gel du point d'indicé dont on
est victime dans la fonction publique
depuis plus de dix ans et on demande
également à ce qu'il n'y ait plus de
fermeture de sa venue sur le territoire
alors il ya les infirmiers et les
médecins mais aussi les aides soignants
beaucoup fustige une mise à mort de
l'hôpital public est ce que vous dirais
qu'aujourd'hui les passions sont en
danger dans les services de points
[Musique]
oui j'aimerais que les patients ils sont
en danger dans la mesure où on est en
sous effectif permanent
comment est ce que vous voulez que nous
soignons s'occuper correctement de la
population sont en permanence en
sous-effectif on nous demande de traiter
de plus en plus de patients avec de plus
en plus de rapidité mon et moins en
moins sur le terrain donc en fait la
problématique c'est le chat qui se mord
la queue
tant qu'on ne le gouvernement ne
s'attardera pas à la revalorisation
salariale des soignants et débloquera
des fonds nécessaires pour sauver la
crise
l'hôpital est effectivement partira vers
une ruine totale
après la vraie question c'est que
veulent les usagers pour l'hôpital
public de demain et que veut le
gouvernement pour l'hôpital public de
demain ça nous en tant que soignant on
n'a pas la clé en main n'a pas les
réponses
on n'a pas la place dans politique non
pas tant il faut que le gouvernement
tranche et passe quelque chose avec
l'hôpital maintenant maintenant que vous
êtes mobilisés pour défendre l'hôpital
public cette manifestation parisienne on
dit qu'elle aura valeur de test
bah je pense que dans un mouvement
forcément les gens écoutaient ce
rapprochement une mobilisation pour
madame la ministre c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose d'important de savoir
combien on va être mobilisé dans la rue
mais en fait la vraie question c'est
combien de soignants cistre dans leur
profession et combien de patients
souffrent de ne pas avoir assez de
pognon sur le terrain parce que tu fais
de ça c'est la vraie question
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions qu'on dise
lafarge porte parole du collectif inter
urgent